[Music]
swastikas were being spray painted in my
locker area they were saying Heil Hitler
I was just heartbroken when I heard what
Kanye said because truthfully it's not
just Kanye that's saying all of this
it's a catalyst for so much more how did
you deal with it what did you do to get
through that moment I took off like any
jewelry that indicated that I was Jewish
and I didn't deny but I'm kind of erased
it from like my personality publicly a
lot of the time because I was just
afraid how many of you have seen
swastikas in school
to most of you okay how many of you have
been subjected to anti-semitic language
in school
the first time you realized what
anti-Semitism was the first time you
experienced it maybe saw it how old were
you I was online I think I was seven or
eight and it was like a super popular
like game and there were these two
trolls I guess and they said hail Hitler
gas the Jews and I still remember those
exact words like so many years later
because they just kind of hit really
deep
and it was kind of like a shaping
experience for me what about social
media do you see a lot of anti-Semitic
language on social media yeah yeah
that's
um that I believe is where I got my I
had my first encounterment with an
anti-semite he ended up texting me one
time in all caps of an oven
[Music]
which is not the same text yeah I did
report his account but like there's no
way of knowing if anything actually
happened do you feel that it's easier
for people to be anti-semitic online
yeah
like a blanket of protection over them
they could go online as any other name
and
like say extremely
extremist things and then if oh no the
account gets banned I'll make another
one I think that social media and pop
culture has had some positive effects on
marginalized communities but we've also
just seen the amplification of
stereotypes and harmful conspiracies
when someone like Kanye West amplifies
those types of messages with his
platform does that give those words more
power yeah yeah unfortunately it does
because if he has a huge fan base his
followers on some social media account
are double the amount of Jews on in the
world which is crazy to think about I
know at least some of them might be
anti-semites and that's a problem it
goes from people you know saying he's
not really like that he's whatever going
through a tough time and then the next
second there are neo-nazis holding up
signs on the 405 freeway on an overpass
saying Kanye was right about the Jews
why should
everybody else care about anti-Semitism
it's not just Jews this can happen to
anybody anti-Semitism right now it's
talking about Jews but there are so many
ways that it could be flipped against
different minority and maybe even
sometimes majority groups any harm being
done to human beings is unacceptable and
no matter who you are it you should care
not because we're Jewish but just
because we're other humans